yeah and one of the terms that uh you
use often which i just absolutely love
is linear commerce explain what that is
and kind of gives maybe an example or
two as to uh
how people are implementing this in the
in the real world
yeah simply put it's the line where
media
meets commerce and for me
that is sort of the center of
a sustainable profitable long-term
viable business
because they can they can uh
influence demand and they can meet that
demand with supply
or they have supply and they can
manufacture that demand
whichever side of the industry they're
coming from so you're seeing
you know you're very familiar with
barstool that's a media company
that became a very commerce focused
brand
there are commerce companies that became
very good
at publishing video right
literature whatever it is i think one of
the examples that i gave
was actually from 1894 yesterday where i
explained that
the founders of michelin tire uh began
michelin ratings because they were
ginning up demand
for tires they knew that um if
you traveled more to heralded
restaurants in france
you would burn more rubber and buy more
tires there are there are
so many examples of that and that's the
core of linear commerce
taking two core functionalities two core
competencies
and making them the focus of your
business
so i think let's use barstool as an
example because i think many people
listening to this will at least have an
idea as to how that business works which
is basically you know it was a blog
then it kind of moved into the social
media realm now there's a lot of video
audio uh type content uh but they also
have a hundred plus million dollar
revenue business
on that and obviously some of that is
advertising i think it's about thirty
percent 33
they've got a big merchandise business
um and then they've got
kind of uh other types of um
of revenue sources how do you look at a
business like that
in terms of merchandise is a very easy
type of kind of linear commerce play
right of just okay we've got eyeballs
we're going to sell them t-shirts right
with kind of all kinds of branding
whatever
where can a business like that go right
and i think of it almost as like as they
mature as a business
the products that they sell become more
sophisticated and
uh not necessarily more complex but just
it's not as easy as like let's put a
print on a t-shirt and sell that through
drop shipping
so how do you see like the evolution of
these companies as they get more serious
about this idea of linear commerce
yeah i think the core of linear commerce
is loyalty right and so
especially from the media side when you
look at barcelona yeah they started off
pretty simply
with uh you know hats and t-shirts and
maybe polo shirts things like that but
what are they doing now they're they've
launched their first
digital app for um for betting they've
launched their own digital sports book
um that's a pretty complex product
they can do that and they can shoot to
number one in sports because
they have a ton of loyalty in their
readership
for barcel probably the next sort of
evolution of that is the physical sports
book
right so when you see pen gaming
launch barstool you know
sports books and or restaurants with
sportsbook capabilities around the
country
market by market i'm not saying that's
what they're going to do but it wouldn't
surprise me if they did it
a lot of that's going to be because of
the loyalty that they've built up over
the over the decade plus they've been in
business
and uh yeah you're going to see more
companies follow that
all that path especially if they have
the types of audiences that uh
that barcelo has yeah and it also feels
like
uh because they've built loyalty to
barstool
they've also built loyalty to the
individual kind of
uh celebrities or personalities uh and
then they almost have these like inside
jokes
uh with that audience and i think that
that kind of drives loyalty but
um i remember seeing in one of the decks
i think with uh penn national gaming
uh the idea that they may launch like uh
pizza shops right so physical locations
that sell pizza under the one bite name
they've got an app
that does that and you kind of start to
realize like wait a second every single
thing that keeps the consumer loyal like
the inside jokes the content like all
that
can be productized to some degree i
think that's kind of what you're getting
at with this linear commerce idea right
right right 100 i don't think there are
many businesses that have done it better
than them
i i know that they're clearly a divisive
and sort of controversial company in
some ways
a lot of people would say that but i
think even
if you are incapable of appreciating
what they've done for their industry
objectively you have to see that they've
they've
succeeded in ways that other businesses
have not
and there are lessons that are
applicable most certainly
to to a number of businesses um i really
wish that people would set aside
some of their distaste for their antics
and just study their business model
because
you know eric has done a wonderful job
like him or not dave is
like he has a midas touch when it comes
to productizing certain verticals and
it's just
it's been interesting to see